Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Morgane Quilfen
L’Intelligence Artificielle - IA -
est-ce que ceux qui en ont
déjà entendu parler
peuvent lever la main
dans la salle pour voir ?
Ouah ! quasiment toute la salle !
Est-ce que ça fait peur à certains ?
Presque la moitié…
La science-fiction
y a largement contribué.
Souvenez-vous du livre
de George Orwell, «1984 »,
(Anglais) « Big brother vous regarde ! »,
ou du film « Minority Report »
où des humains mutants
arrivaient à prédire des crimes,
avant même qu’ils n’aient eu lieu,
ou même du film « Her »
dans lequel le héros tombait
amoureux d’une machine.
Nous avons tous cru
que c’était impossible,
que jamais la science ne serait
capable de créer de tels systèmes.
L’intelligence artificielle
intrigue, passionne,
mais inquiète aussi.
Il ne se passe pas une semaine
sans que nous entendions :
« Que va devenir l’être humain ? »,
« Les machines vont-elles
nous dépasser ? », etc.
On entend tout et son contraire.
Je vous propose de revenir aux images
visionnées au début de cette présentation,
ici, Alpha Go.
En 2016, cette machine a été capable
de battre le meilleur joueur
du monde de Go à plate couture.
Le jeu de Go est un jeu
qui est pourtant assez simple :
seulement neuf règles.
Mais le nombre de combinaisons possibles
excède le nombre d’atomes
connus dans l’univers.
Des prouesses remarquables ont
également eu lieu dans le domaine médical,
où des systèmes sont capables
de détecter des tumeurs cancéreuses
bien plus efficacement
que des médecins expérimentés.
Ici, dans l’industrie,
la maintenance prédictive
arrive à détecter des anomalies avant même
qu’elles ne deviennent critiques.
Et puis, pour finir,
dans nos vies quotidiennes,
des assistants virtuels nous
aident à trouver des informations
ou à effectuer des tâches,
qui sont plus ou moins utiles,
je vous l’accorde.
« Hey, Magic Assistant !
peux-tu s'il te plaît rajouter du fromage
à raclette sur la liste de courses ? »
Mais cette science
ne date pas d’aujourd’hui.
En 1956, des scientifiques
se sont réunis.
Ils rêvaient d’un nouveau monde,
d’un monde où l’on pourrait recréer
toutes les fonctions cognitives humaines,
dans une machine.
Derrière l’intelligence artificielle
se cache la volonté
de créer des outils
et des systèmes performants,
mais surtout, de percer
les mystères de l’intelligence.
Oui, de percer les mystères
de l’intelligence !
L’intelligence... Il est difficile
de définir ce concept complexe.
« Intelligere » en latin signifie
la capacité à faire des liens.
Avec l’intelligence artificielle,
nous souhaitons qu’une machine
devienne intelligente.
Vous vous posez probablement la question :
comment une machine fait-elle
pour acquérir des informations,
faire des liens, raisonner,
et ensuite générer
de nouvelles connaissances ?
Oui, elle doit tout simplement
être capable d’apprendre.
L’une des façons d’apprendre,
pour une machine,
repose sur l'intelligence artificielle
statistique, fondée sur les données.
Les termes « apprentissage
automatique » ou « machine learning »
vous sont probablement familiers.
Alors, partons d’un exemple.
Imaginons que vous êtes
un agent immobilier à La Baule
et que vous avez collecté
beaucoup d’informations
sur des biens aux alentours de La Baule.
Pour chaque bien, vous avez
récolté des informations
comme la taille du jardin,
la superficie du salon,
le nombre de chambres,
l’exposition géographique,
l’emplacement géographique, etc.,
plein d’informations,
et puis son prix.
En fournissant toutes
ces données à une machine,
la machine va être capable
d’apprendre à prédire le prix d’un bien.
Comment ?
En effectuant des calculs statistiques,
en faisant des liens
entre toutes ces informations.
À aucun moment vous n’allez intervenir
pour lui dire exactement
comment réaliser cette tâche.
Mais par contre,
là où votre rôle est primordial,
c’est dans les données
que vous allez lui fournir.
Si vous ne lui donnez pas
suffisamment d’exemples représentatifs,
la machine ne sera pas capable
de prédire tous les cas.
À l’heure actuelle,
l'intelligence artificielle
ne sait réaliser que des tâches
simples, spécialisées et répétitives.
Et comme nous l’avons
vu dans certains cas,
elle est capable de réaliser des tâches
mieux que nous, les humains.
On parle alors
d’intelligence artificielle faible,
car, pour l’instant,
la machine ne sait pas encore
généraliser ses propres apprentissages.
Tout l’enjeu de l’IA de demain sera
de générer de nouvelles connaissances,
de passer d’une intelligence
artificielle faible,
à une intelligence artificielle forte.
Depuis les années 2000,
l’intelligence artificielle statistique
connaît un véritable essor.
Ses prouesses sont
le résultat de trois facteurs :
premièrement,
des données de plus en plus
présentes et accessibles ;
deuxièmement,
des capacités de calcul
de plus en plus performantes ;
et troisièmement,
des algorithmes qui permettent de résoudre
des tâches de plus en plus complexes.
Beaucoup de ces systèmes utilisent
des réseaux de neurones artificiels,
des réseaux qui contiennent des neurones,
un peu comme dans nos cerveaux.
Un neurone artificiel, c’est une unité
mathématique de calculs simples.
La particularité,
c’est que tous les résultats
des calculs d’une couche
vont servir d’entrée
au calcul des autres couches.
Chaque couche permet ainsi
d’approfondir petit à petit
la compréhension du problème.
Cette technique est appelée
le « deep learning »,
ou « apprentissage profond ».
Elle a permis des avancées majeures
comme, par exemple,
dans la reconnaissance vocale -
vous dictez tous des ordres
à vos téléphones –
ou dans la vision par ordinateur –
certains systèmes, certaines voitures
vont anticiper leur freinage
dès lors qu’elles
vont détecter des piétons.
Tous ces réseaux de neurones artificiels
ne sont pas copiés sur nos réseaux
de neurones biologiques.
Ils s’en inspirent.
Oui ! Ils sont bio-inspirés.
Alors, parlons de notre
cerveau quelques instants,
et en particulier
de celui des pilotes d’avion.
Je vais vous raconter
une histoire incroyable, mais vraie.
Un pilote et son copilote
sont à bord de leur avion.
Ils veulent atterrir.
Problème !
Un avion, sur la piste d'atterrissage,
leur bloque le passage.
Le pilote et le co-pilote
sont focalisés sur cet événement.
Au même moment,
dans le cockpit, une alarme
sonore stridente retentit.
Mais, ils l’ignorent.
Ils sont trop focalisés
sur l’avion encore sur la piste.
L’avion décolle et ils entament
leur atterrissage.
L’alarme sonore, qu’ils ont ignorée,
avait pour but de leur signaler
qu'ils n'avaient pas sorti
le train d'atterrissage.
Je vous rassure -
parce que je vous sens inquiets -
ils vont bien !
Par contre, ils ont été
trahis par leur cerveau.
Nous savons que les neuroscientifiques
utilisent des casques avec capteurs,
ou des imageries médicales
pour mesurer nos ondes cérébrales.
Ils récoltent ainsi
une grande quantité de données,
et avec ces données, ils arrivent à mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Dans l’exemple précédent
des pilotes d’avion,
qui souffrent dans ce cas
de « surdité inattentionnelle »,
l’objectif des neuroscientifiques
est de comprendre les mécanismes cérébraux
se mettant en place dans ces situations.
Leur objectif, à terme, est de créer
des cockpits plus intelligents,
s’adaptant à l’état du pilote.
Comment font ces neuroscientifiques
pour analyser toutes ces données ?
Tout simplement,
ils ont recours à des outils
comme l’informatique, les mathématiques
ou l’intelligence artificielle.
C’est ce qu’on appelle les
« neurosciences computationnelles ».
Alors, pourquoi parler
d’intelligence artificielle
et de neurosciences en même temps ?
Tout simplement
car dans ces deux situations,
le neurone est au cœur
de toutes les préoccupations.
L’intelligence artificielle a besoin,
pour continuer à s’améliorer,
de s’inspirer des découvertes
faites en neurosciences.
Elle pourra ainsi créer
des systèmes encore plus intelligents,
basés sur des réseaux de neurones
encore plus performants.
Et inversement,
les neurosciences ont besoin
de l’intelligence artificielle
pour continuer à l’aider à tester
et à formaliser de nouvelles théories.
Finalement,
nous vivons déjà
dans le « siècle du cerveau ».
Nous sommes déjà entrés
dans un monde « neurocentrique »,
pour preuve l'avènement
de nouvelles neurodisciplines
comme la neuroéconomie, la neuroergonomie,
le neuromarketing,
voire la neuroéducation.
Nous vivons déjà à l’ère de la
quatrième révolution industrielle,
celle de la révolution technologique.
Aucune révolution n’a été
aussi rapide que celle-ci,
modifiant notre façon
de vivre, de travailler,
mais également notre rapport aux autres.
Avant même d’être technologique,
la transformation
de l’intelligence artificielle
est humaine, culturelle et sociétale.
Dans le travail, tous les secteurs
d’activité sont touchés,
que ce soit la santé, l’agriculture,
la justice, l’éducation, les transports,
mais également tous les métiers,
bouleversant ainsi
l’organisation des entreprises.
L’un des principaux objectifs
de l’intelligence artificielle
sera de faire accepter, partout
et par tous, ces nouveaux outils
qui aident, optimisent ou remplacent
les tâches jusqu’ici
réalisées par les humains.
Vous, vos enfants, vos petits-enfants,
vos arrières-petits-enfants
vivrez demain dans un monde
où hommes et machines
cohabiteront, sans aucun doute,
de plus en plus intelligemment.
Pour moi, cette association
homme-machine
donnera naissance
à une collaboration plus efficace,
dans laquelle l’homme aura plus de temps,
et pourra se consacrer à des tâches
plus motivantes et gratifiantes.
Vous ne devrez pas tous devenir
des experts en IA et en neurosciences,
mais par contre,
vous devrez tous comprendre
les enjeux stratégiques et économiques
de ces nouveaux outils.
Cela vous permettra de prendre conscience
du potentiel et des limites
de ces technologies.
Alors, avec l’intelligence
artificielle et les neurosciences,
l’homme n’a décidément
pas fini de se redécouvrir.
Je vous remercie pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)